hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today we are playing
another part
of resident evil 8. i am now in a hotel
room in australia and we are going to
lose the light
at some point pretty soon we just
finished
house um benviento which i'm actually
going to have a separate dedicated video
about because
i'm still thinking about how awesome
that design was and
now i think i'm yeah just collecting
other pieces of my
[ __ ] daughter i'm still not sure what
to do about this it didn't seem like
there was anything there there's some
piece of it that seems to be missing
um i guess i just gotta go back to the
town
it was i still don't have anything for
that do i
no what is that for i feel like it's
been too long oh that's right that's
that's the one on the bottom
yeah i still don't have
anything that's going to help me legs
floss this [ __ ] game
um oh and this doesn't have a lot of
ammo let's do some crafting real quick
just please not that that helped a ton
but we'll take what we can get i did get
this sick new shotgun
okay
okay i was worried that wasn't supposed
to be locked but it was this
is this gonna break i wonder if you can
go back to the house
i genuinely don't know
why the music gets spooky
why did it
it's zombies now isn't it these are
zombies it's almost like
resident evil oh [ __ ] i hear them
oh god i don't want anything to do with
any of you
i oh my god i would like to leave
i i i'm i'm get out of here with my ammo
thank you and not waste time on your
shitty zombies that would have given me
money
no no i'm not we no we're not doing it
does this look
familiar to you
well that was weird it's just because
i've procured some new items for you mr
winters
we have [ __ ] that i can sell you can
sell that
i need to make my webcam a little bit
smaller so i can read
there we go yeah we sell that
we can't sell that yet that would be a
bad idea
i could sell that that's i found the
head for that oh this is so much money
damn i still got all this [ __ ] meat
um okay ah miss angie just adorable
porcelain dolls are very popular you
know fine to disagree
so i'm wondering if i can i don't have
any fish
just give him stuff um
like carry on i can to store
i was wondering that because it seems so
weird that i would have to just carry
around my own
ah thank you meat did i get rid of all
of it then
i did hardly wait for the okay but yes
i like the juke a whole lot oh there are
new supplies is what you're telling me
flashbangs and explosive rounds i will
take
that one huh wait what are the other two
live grip for the handgun
improved gun stock for the shotgun i'm
going to do that
it's expensive you'll be slaughtering
things cash up dude what do i care
i care about the scope i'm never going
to use it um let's take that too oh
excellent cool
um yeah so i sold
the lemmy for anyone who might have
missed that
um well you all would have missed that
because i edited it out of the video
because
it was uh just busy work basically
um
[Music]
let's just do all of this you know um
my logic was basically that i didn't
feel like i needed to have
i don't know that i need to have two
shotguns either you know
one moment please i probably don't
um i'm gonna buy some shotgun ammo as
well
i can only get two cool
beautiful till next we meet
single bullet oh no there's more than
that oh you have a lock pick now
which i'm a fan of let's just move you
down here
and then probably move you up here i
think i should probably make a decision
between one of the two shotguns though
if i examine this
840 power that's all i'm really going to
care about isn't it and then this one
is 800 power but it's level four
so this one's gonna be the better
shotgun which means i could sell this i
want for now but
just keep that in mind going forward of
which i wanted to keep it which i
i'm okay with getting rid of and then
i'll be view over here
beautiful okay time to look at the map
can i open that now potentially i'm
gonna go right to here just
keep clearing that map out just keep
clearing it out there's gonna be [ __ ]
zombies here now though of course there
are the graveyards gonna have zombies
for sure now
i don't love that i'm gonna go to that
house anyway let's do it
that really is all the shocking ammo
that i have hmm
you do not love to see it
[ __ ] [ __ ] just stay in the ground
stay in the ground stay in the ground
this is the one that i've been meaning
to lockpick for my entire life
isn't it yeah it is yeah
nope of course we've already seen that
it's gonna be whatever's in here
ah why i think i will
thank you
you know what god bless also
wrong button this is like pawn to me
look at this
beautiful what
well of course i i didn't even know that
was there
can i still get to that
who gave you the right to be that noisy
right now
what the [ __ ] um
okay
just trying to think about what i want
to do you know i still i can get in
there let's go there
out through can i go through this way
every [ __ ] pathway is blocked
and i don't trust this graveyard for a
second now
okay how do i get there this way
maybe
it's been like not even that many days
since i last played it and i have no
idea where i'm going now
okay there is a ladder here
i think that just gets you inside this
house though right
no is this the one i fell into yeah um
can i run over that
i don't know okay that's not gonna be
right then
so i'm gonna have to go up around this
way
in through there i think
[ __ ] this dude [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
you
i'm on to you i hear what you're doing i
hear these shitty noises you're making
i don't want anything to do with it
nope
yes
oh no i don't know
i don't know no no no no because it
knows that i'm gonna be going to this
house right surely
um
it's too peaceful and quiet
i am gonna get jumped
is somebody mean gonna be in this house
or is it this house
it is this house
okay cool hey hello yep
just coming here opening the store
minding my own business
hello anybody
like one upside of the lichens is that i
feel like they're just sort of
loud in general whereas
zombies can be real quiet until they
[ __ ]
change their minds and get noisy you
know
okay okay
who lived here joel from the last of us
right
because he makes guitars that's a thing
he did
oh interesting
okay her fifth birthday
oh it's gonna be on the calendar that
was in here
27 oh 9 17.
maybe not 17 though because she's 5
27
yes 09 now wrong way every time you do
this
17
that's right cool that's convenient
hello my proud friend
cool okay i will equip that thank you
not that i'm using the shotgun very much
i mean the sniper rifle uh what else did
i just [ __ ] pick up
whatever the hell that was
what do i have that for where was that
taken
that was taken in the graveyard
i knew i had to go there what have you
just done with this weird
i would like to look at it please
okay it says very valuable so i'm
guessing you're supposed to sell it
uh why do you want me to look at my
inventory again i think i'm all right i
think i have everything needed
have i looted this house i still have
not looted this house okay
roger that i will loot
the house can i see anything
flicker
any of you sons of [ __ ] flickering
what else could it be you will not best
me resident evil
this one no
just wanted to make sure you know
it's [ __ ] there's no way you'd put
these here
what are you [ __ ] got a gem i swear
to god
it is jerks that's so rude
eh yeah all right
i don't want to do it but i'm going to
go to the graveyard
i guess that's what it wants me to do of
a
video game um right now there's gonna be
zombie like man there's something else i
can do around here right no
oh what's uh that's right i still can't
get through there and let's say whatever
key that is no i can't
i can't excuse me
okay back up and around i believe
that's some wrestling is it just these
nice goat uh head ornaments that i'm
sure are not real goats definitely
just nice goat art i think somebody
in the town is a a
puppet uh maker or a sculptor of sorts
and they just you know went to work on
nice goat designs i believe is what
happened there okay
cool cool cool
ready i don't give a [ __ ] what was that
look at me being scared by scarecrows
they work turns out hang on i'm gonna
move my webcam a little bit
mmm that's a lot of sounds gonna do that
and then i'll just pull myself over
slightly so i don't have to lean in as
much
okay this is going to be great and i'm
really excited about it
actually
it's behind [ __ ] knew it i
[ __ ] oh that just opened
well that's interesting
oh they made me make more like vampires
because that would explain
the um
situation
maybe they're not zombies resident evil
is that it why is there still music can
you chill
okay everybody chill can you stay in the
ground i it says rest in peace for a
reason
okay well it's in your best interest
oh that's for um
the thingy and there's your blue boat oh
god i guess i'm gonna shoot
i'm sorry mate like you are beautiful
but this game only has
one option and it's shoot everything may
you slumber only for a short while i
take back
everything i said about rest in peace
um okay there was a treasure through
here right
i'm going to go save because it's in
this house right here
it makes it very easy changed in here
yet
nobody you still looking for me
where is this lab what the hell i'm just
gonna say we're just gonna save
right here okay and then we're gonna go
check this treasure out
see if i can't get to it
i would have suspected that you know
that's kind of what i would have thought
there are fish i can kill here
that's good i have been eating fish get
back here
i'm sorry i'm really sorry
that's what that fish turned into all
right
hottest part of the game [ __ ]
[ __ ] it crouch up close to you fish
i think i'm scared of zombies and
vampires and that [ __ ] doll house nah
just these [ __ ] get of get your
ass
get
ethan move faster while crouching he's
circling you he's making you look like
an idiot it makes you look like a coward
okay cool that's exactly what i wanted
and it went super smoothly
can i just walk up there nah
i don't know what i'm gonna do about
that
oh i miss you queen
um there's also that oh wait wait wait
wait wait that's going to loop back
around
when i get whatever is needed for that
i'm gonna be just fine i'm gonna be just
fine
disregard all panic pull out actual gun
okay go drop
fish off to large man
i think i'm making great progress this
is a huge dub for me
all right hey buddy hello
welcome hey
not wrong john girl
okay used to be alive
it's an inefficient way to do this what
else have i given him things for
fish finest fish you say
let's just do this one but yeah
no no needs one that makes sense and you
can have the rest of my fish
cool would you like yellow quartz
a crystal skull a steel crab slicker
uh i need to keep my juicy game i forgot
i even had that okay
what yes splendid do you know it's worth
well i i hopefully it's whatever you
sold it to me for because um
if not i just got [ __ ] cool
cool i'm skilled at all sorts of weapons
modifications and we'll do them for a
small
you know what i'm saying i think we're
gonna do this one this simple motor and
then i am
done just a moment buy more shotgun ammo
which feels very weird in this game
but
you know why not for now you just
have a wonderful adventure thanks buddy
why did you say it like you were mocking
me
i'm just going to move all this down
here
13 is not even that much now i'm
reconsider maybe i should have bought
more
maybe i should need more than 30. i
don't know
okay what do we want to do next can i go
through this way yet or do i still need
like
um 10 more fetuses or whatever
oh oh my
wow so i could go back
i i kind of want to go for this one
which i'm hoping this just all loops
around here and it's not
too terrible this is going to be
an area though isn't it maybe it's not
you know maybe it's not maybe maybe
maybe it's maybe it'll be fine
because this is where he actually is
wario or whatever moro um
and i have the slab for that now let's
just do this first
shall we just
move this part of town and nice
just it's just what i wanted actually
i was prepared
[Applause]
no no no
not what i had hoped for [ __ ]
i really thought this was just gonna be
fine i thought that i was just gonna
come
you know just visit this section of town
the wounds are severe i won't last much
longer i can hear it shuffling about
outside i barely flinch when i shot it i
feel like it's toying with me that is no
wolf
he's not wrong i won't lay down like a
dog if i can get the old watermelon i
can stop it
i can protect you i'm so close damn i'm
so cold my legs won't move i'm sorry
louise please forgive me
sorry buddy that's a huge elfie
okay can i kill this thing
i'm going to guess not
there's nothing up here but let's take a
look anyway shall we
here i was really thinking it's just
going to be another part of town
there'll be some zombies
and i'll just go this way to kind of
raw
to just clear out the
remaining
it wants me to get to the this is where
it wants me to go
right [ __ ] me
i have to stealth i really don't know if
i can kill you
my friend
okay we'll find out i guess
oh my oh boy
okay all right everybody's just
just how did he find me so fast in the
beginning
where are you you can [ __ ] hear me
where the [ __ ] is it
okay i'm just assuming
this little hidey hole it doesn't really
want to [ __ ] with hopefully maybe
it's just not interested it likes to be
free
you know spread its fur
doesn't really have interest in
the basements of houses hopefully
if i was a majestic beast such as ye
i wouldn't be in here that's disgusting
this is uh for peasants
and you sir are a god hey chick chickens
can you not [ __ ]
blow my cover right now i'm gonna need
you to shut up excuse me
holy [ __ ] see what i'm dealing with
okay he's not in this house
he's not he's not he's not he's not
why would he be in this house that would
be [ __ ] ridiculous i thought that
that train was
oh no okay cool
all right mate yeah yeah yeah i hear you
i hear you
where's the herb all right
this is the most herbs this game has
given me in quite some time
not my finest inventory management work
let's rotate you and just put you out
there
and then move these over wolf i know
you're outside but i'm actually going
through my inventory right now
so if you could just give me a minute um
just let me
just let me do this uh we'll be i'll be
right with you
thanks okay can i get through whatever
this lock door is
mechanical door
probably not
but let's take a look it's not like
there's any
imminent threat right there
i'm not worried about anything that's
happening right now personally
is this where the chickens are no it's
like around there
can't get through there can i
i'm going to go back through the house
to whence
i entered and then try to go around the
back i think
just to see i'm trying to visit my
chicken friends
i know you're out there somewhere
but i do not wish you any ill will
my friend you do not need
music music is happening
music is happening you do not need to
worry about me
[ __ ] that's okay maybe i shouldn't be
here yet
okay i think
yeah maybe i'm not supposed to be here
yet but i also always suspected that
that was the water wheel weapon is that
gonna give me the the
it is i do need to be here if the water
will weapon is probably gonna give me
the
the [ __ ] wheel so i just don't wanna
go down here because big boy's probably
down here
and i suspect that right now he can't be
killed
so i need to cross this river somewhere
where to cross where to cross probably
it probably is all the way down here but
i'm gonna [ __ ] pass him but [ __ ]
i'm gonna see if there's maybe anywhere
else
that i could am i walking towards him
right now
oh that's where it is why is he sound so
close
buddy why do you sound like you're very
close to me
you are that's why i think i can cross
right there that's what i'm gonna try
and do
oh that's the water wheel great okay
just keep going
huge fan of your work i think you're
very scary
oh i would hate to see how scary you are
up close
no need to show me thank you
okay have a good day i don't know what
this accent that i'm doing is
great
another oh this is gonna be explosies
yeah sick
i mean you tried you didn't try very
hard but you tried
it's just so just a lot oh explosive
rounds where did i see the lock pick
there loves a lockpick okay so it's not
what i thought
i expected water wheel weapon to mean
something associated with me finding
water wheels
um we can come back out here now
he's not gonna he's not gonna cross the
river like that would be that would just
be weird why would he
what how [ __ ] dare you
not be unlocked from this side what kind
of
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that can i get
around from here
buddy i need to say hi
just two different people doing
different bigs ah that's annoying
well i but i want to go here um because
i did not get any of the things that i
thought that i was going to get from
here
that did not happen as i suspected that
it would
you have to go down here surely not
surely not
all right we are going to go do that so
that i feel like i've done it we've
cleared this out pretty well
i'm supposed to go back to the altar
right now no surely not or am i still
carrying her
did i not put i didn't put the legs
flask in there that's my bad
sorry about it hey okay
yeah very scabby who am i you're scary
he's gonna run i'm just gonna run he's
he hates doors everybody knows
he can't get through doors terrified of
him he can't
get out here
who would have known where was he doors
okay uh let me give you my daughter's
legs
which is a completely normal thing to
say
and to have happen in any video game
naturally great cool
going to go open the final
lock picked door well that's not even
locked now what do you mean
um which is this house right here right
here right here right here right here
everybody stay in the ground nobody
[ __ ] wants anything to do with you
just stay in the ground
show your mouth just rest in peace
would not involve getting up out of the
ground now would it
did you stay there okay
you know what i keep pressing the wrong
button every time i press y
but oh my god
this is we just ignore that bit
here prettiest map i've ever seen
in my whole life huh it's beautiful
and beautiful ah
you'd love to see it let's go save um
should i tag this is not safe for work
because i just put
porn on youtube also
i don't watch people on youtube play
through video games are they all like
this
i'm sure they don't do this in their
playthroughs
i'm sure nobody else is like let me give
people good content by making
sure that i turn the red room's all blue
because nobody [ __ ] cares with me
okay cool yeah
and then i think we probably go back to
talk to the duke as my guest
because i put the legs in the thing and
then i guess
i probably should have saved money
to buy the ability to make explosive
rounds
so there is that
hey bud anything to say to me fan ah
yes yes no he doesn't
huh it's fair enough to hunger
used to be alive
interesting selection still don't care
about mines very much
i could buy another pipe bomb they're
pretty handy
oh can i craft them i think i can i
don't know
well we'll leave it here for now please
come again
this is a lot of weapons we've we've
gathered here isn't it
i've just got a text message hello mate
um all right
start stacking the ammo up over here
shall we
so we can make this a little bit tidier
no worries mate
beautiful
okay
well if i can't do that yet
i can't do that yet
i can't do that yet that's all locked
i could probably go somewhere around
here
the village itself i cannot go through
there
where am i i guess i should go back
deal with this
it just i'm nervous about it because
it's associated with a
grave is sort of my problem um
i don't know that it's going to have a
tremendous amount of chill
i don't feel like this is one of those
situations where i just sort of walk up
there
put the stone in and give whatever it
intends to
to to to get who killed me
but i guess we'll find out i can't wait
i also like really if i'm being honest
never would have wanted to go back to
the [ __ ]
of a creepy house but at least mia's not
showing up now
um my stupid dead wife who won't stay
dead
no matter what the amount of times that
this woman has died
my god which i guess if anything means
we're sort of i have to go back
around here now uh means i sort of
perfect for each other
being that i too am pretty much
invincible
oh no
how to go around from here uh
it's around this way it is around that
way my bad
excuse me
okay
and then i think i can save
oh hang on there's a goat here what
tell me there's a [ __ ]
goat here somewhere there's a beast
but where was it here last time uh oh
that's the scariest thing i've seen in
this whole game so far
you're really not going to attack me
you're literally the devil
that's what the [ __ ] the sound was
that i heard
oh i feel bad when they just i really
hyped you up and
you sort of let me down mate you were
not you know
anyway okay um
should i save here i think i should i
don't know if this could be literally
nothing and i could just be nervous for
absolutely no reason but
i like to be prepared when i find out
if that's the case so we're gonna just
save right here
and then keep moving
all right
i wonder what it is that made uh
goats be associated with devil imagery
they don't know the source of that um
all these thoughts and more uh subscribe
to a lot of peers on youtube
it's a lot of nervous talking really
see there's no way oh my god what the
[ __ ]
oh oh oh oh my god oh my god
oh no no no no no no we're off to a bad
start we're off to a bad start
i don't feel good about any of it holy
[ __ ]
oh my god oh i oh
i didn't even
i didn't even put the thing in there
probably not gonna need the knife
buddy
[Music]
does he not come up the stairs though no
he does he's super does
[ __ ] sake no leave me alone leave me
alone
well this makes me feel like i'm just
cheesing it though
but we'll get the job done won't we what
happened in that animation buddy
how strong is this guy i should be
surprised
and i also should start missing
no no no no no no i'm okay thank you i'm
okay thank you
i'm okay oh my god okay buddy i guess we
do go upstairs
i'm sorry no no no no no no no no we're
okay we're okay you don't we're fights
you can go back down it's okay we don't
need to be this close
social distancing
i know you're upset so am i i thought
that something bad was gonna happen here
but when i said bad i expected scary not
well not that you're not scary that was
very brutal but i didn't expect like
oh [ __ ] more of that um i didn't expect
this
jesus christ i need to remember whatever
the shortcut is for
healing is it just it's just lb uh
hey bud hello i missed you so much i
decided to come back and say hi
no ethan ethan ethan ethan ethan we took
a risk there
also i'm really blaming ethan but it's
my fault
very excited to hang out with you and
get one [ __ ] shot off oh my god oh my
god
i should i should have been uploading
the sniper rifle shouldn't i
aren't you gonna turn around i'm not
halfway here mate bloody oh just turn
around didn't it
oh i'm out oh no
ah i forgot that i have that new gun
though
that's what i should be doing but i
don't have any [ __ ] ammo for it
it's this boy we're gonna shortcut you
over here because that's out now can we
craft
mistakes were made but you can't know
the mistakes until
you make the mistakes that's what i'm
saying
oh that seems good he didn't like that
that was
he didn't like that come back come back
yeah that's he doesn't like that but if
i fail this now because i went prepared
then i'm thinking
i feel like i cheated i thought the
whole axe
i shook the whole microphone i feel like
i cheated i should have done that fight
properly
i feel a little bit bad about it um but
i'm sure i'll play through this game
again
you know and i was just like well i'm
aware that i cannot equip myself
appropriately for this fight so that's
the reality that we are in right now
stay down you little [ __ ]
you're all oh you've got you've got like
a matching axe i think you want to be
like your hero
you're just trying to be a coordinated
you think you're as cool as the big guy
okay let's put it the slide the thing in
the slab oh is that the treasure surely
not
um broken slap
that's great i love this not at all
ominous actually this is um
actually extremely chill wonderful
wonderful i kind of just want to see if
you can get back in here
you can
interesting um but we're not going to
you know let's let's have a look at the
chalice
the chalice
i can't use it oh i really thought they
were gonna give me an
axe okay we just go sell both of those
then
all right fine
go back past our goat friend who's dead
i have so much stuff to give the duke
he's going to think i'm a [ __ ]
champion you can be so proud of me
and there's still going to be zombies
out here i'm pretty sure
and i should try to craft more explosive
ammo but i
do not have anything to craft with
i'm also just not sure where to go next
actually um because i feel like i really
need that wheel whatever that is
i'm hankering for that
okay
cool running through see maybe i should
be killing them to get the resources
what do i care about handgun ammo
honestly
when has anyone ever needed it oh
they're all gone anyway okay
back to the duke hello
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the time
i'll take it i guess food is life
uh the chalice aha
duke's kitchen what did i just get
um
but i should be really splitting these
up in more efficient ways shouldn't i
yeah let's take that back i can't
oh great i've screwed this up terribly
this is very unorganized alana you've
not done a good job here
i still don't care about the mines
what now maybe we can't upgrade the um
oh there's so many upgrades for all of
this stuff that i wasn't even paying
attention to
uh look
i'm gonna do that because i was just
complaining about it
it's fine all finished do that just in
case
you know just because i was just
bitching about it
which shotgun should i focus on i wonder
let's do that and
the rifles all i really have left to use
i'm skilled at all sorts of weapons
yeah yeah yeah i know you're [ __ ]
your champion
we're all a huge fan of you i'm just
gonna buy another pipe bomb because i
spent one
and then i guess just i just kind of
want to save the money so
again just why should i actually use the
wall interesting selection
ah that's fair that was bound to happen
eventually
um yeah i sold my lemmy all right
thank you for your patronage of course
i'm a huge fan
um let me just reorganize real quick
cool nope didn't move these over
now cool great
can craft that that is what we want to
craft
beautiful okay what have i got that's
new now we've used that
um treasure map we've also done family
photo we already used
well wheels already been used all right
just more for winged unborn
whatever the [ __ ] um
what was that oh
i this whole time had not realized that
that was right there
and i was running back into town to save
and that's been there the whole time
[ __ ] sake okay
so my guess is that right now this is
the only place i can go
and that was what's going to lead me out
this way um from
here through that beast that i'm still
not positive if i can kill
and i probably can in any case i think i
will do that next time glad we got
recording to work i'm sorry if you can
hear a little
harm i am in a hotel room they never
perfectly sound um but that is it for me
today everyone
i will see you next time for part nine
thank you